NATHAN: Hi and welcome,
everybody, to Talks at Google.
Today, I have the pleasure of
introducing Brian Solis, who
is the author of "What's the
Future of Business (WTF)."
He's a well-renowned digital
analyst, author, and has a
great blog.
I also encourage you to go visit
my personal favorite at
go/shaqbrian, which is a
great interview of--
Brian giving an interview
to Shaquille O'Neill.
So without further ado, I'll
let Brian take it away.
BRIAN SOLIS: Thanks, Nathan.
Well, good afternoon.
Thank you for spending
the Friday with me
before a long weekend.
I'm a digital analyst.
I study technology and its
impact on business.
And on nights and weekends,
I like to say that I'm an
aspiring digital
anthropologist.
I like to look at how technology
is impacting you
and me and how it starts to
change sort of who we are,
forms of self expression, how
we communicate with one
another, and ultimately how that
makes us or helps us or
improves or changes the way
that we make decisions.
Because in that world between
analysis and anthropology is a
greater understanding of
how to get in front
of how we're changing.
And nothing really says change
and innovation and
transformation as much as a
PowerPoint presentation.
Now that I think about it,
with a small room that's
probably not the best choice.
But I will just kind of flip
through some slides, and then
I'd love to just hear
your questions.
One of the things that I find
most fascinating is that when
I'm not working with technology
companies and
working with big brands and
enterprise organizations to
help them figure out how do
embrace innovation and
technology as a way of improving
engagement-- whether
it's with customers, whether
it's with employees, whether
it's using technology as a way
to improve products or
processes or services--
and what's consistent in almost
every case is this
inability to really understand
the role that people play in
the whole process.
Technology is part of it.
But things like transparency,
communication, empowerment,
listening to people, thinking
about the problems that they
have and how to improve those
processes that contribute to
the problems or the
products that
contribute to the problems.
None of this really is part of
the decision-making cycle at
the enterprise executive
level.
I actually believe this
contributes to what I call
digital Darwinism.
Technology and society
are evolving.
It's just a reality.
And a lot of businesses and
organizations and governments
aren't evolving along with it.
And that creates a problem where
we're trying to solve it
with technology where we will
say, networks, tablets,
smartphones.
These are all ways that
we're communicating.
So therefore, the answer has to
lie with the device or has
to lie with the network.
When in fact it's more cultural,
it's more human.
Understanding this
difference--
if I was a relationship
counselor, you would talk to
somebody in a marriage
and say, well
there's what you said.
And there's what they heard.
And often, they're different.
So allowing yourself to step
outside of, say, you and think
more about the people, the
markets, the opportunities
allow you to see things in
a very different light.
I'm not sure if anybody has
watched that show "Undercover
Boss," but it's one of
my favorite shows.
Even though it has the same
exact ending every episode,
there's a beauty in the
validation that
happens at the end.
It's sort of this gift of
empathy that executives get
from having to walk in the
footsteps of their customers
or their employees and in turn
seeing, essentially, what it
is that they have missed
all along.
They'll always say the
same thing, too.
They'll say, I forgot
what it was like.
And that's important.
Because when you start to
remember what it's like, or
when you get to see what the
challenge or the problem is--
you've probably heard of the
book "The Innovator's
Dilemma." You sort of play on
words and you realize it's the
dilemma's innovator that can
pave a way to a brighter, more
meaningful future where empathy
plays a key role in
all of this.
What it all nets out
too is that, yes,
technology is pervasive.
It's part of our everyday
life now.
And when you post a selfie on
your favorite network of
choice, and you don't get as
many reactions as you hoped,
that affects you.
So you do it again.
Or you find a more interesting
way to evoke that type of
engagement or reaction that
validates why you did it in
the first place.
And as we start to do this,
there's a self-empowerment in
the process.
You place yourself at the
center of everything.
I call the egosystem, and I use
that word lovingly, where
you are literally at the center
of your universe, where
people, businesses, anything
that's important to you sort
of revolves around you.
And you, too, revolve around
the other things that are
important to you.
Why is this important?
Because at the center of all
of this, understanding this
human algorithm--
what makes us tick, what's
important to us, how are we
changing, and how are we forcing
others to change
around us--
I believe, requires not only
study but innovation.
So I brought some of these books
that I'm going to leave
behind for anybody that
has a long drive this
weekend or a flight.
Because I want to share
my story with you.
I wish I had more time
in the world.
If I did, I would fix how we
teach kids in school because
we're adapting old processes
to new ways of thinking.
And it's almost the same problem
across the board,
whether it's a government
or business.
It's just that we're taking what
we know and we're trying
to stuff what's new into old
processes and methodologies.
And I thought, wow, well
you know what?
I'm an author.
This is, I think, my sixth
or seventh book.
There is no way I could sit
down and write another
400-page business book.
I just can't.
In the last year and a half
since I've published my last
book, a lot's happened.
I'm part of maybe too
many networks.
I'm definitely tethered to too
many devices, in good ways.
But just my ability to think and
write, consume, it's now
more bursting than it is
consistent or continual like
the way it used to be.
It's not a bad thing.
I actually think I've learned
more in the process.
So then I started to think about
textbooks and kids and
how they learn or how they're
having difficulty learning.
And how maybe we're prescribing
medication to them
to get them to focus rather than
maybe innovating in ways
that help them focus
their way.
So I thought about the book,
the concept of a book, and
decided why would I write a book
the same old way on the
same old paper with the same
all font when I could and
should develop a book that would
be the way I would want
to consume it or the way a
younger millennial or Gen-Z
would want to consume it?
And so I spent about a year or
so studying UX and design and
studying how you and I read on
tablets, and how we read on
smartphones, and what
makes us share.
What become something
that's shareable?
What makes us engage with
the piece of content?
And the idea of a book
went out the window.
The idea, then, of an analog app
started to come into view.
And how I wrote, the way I wrote
a sentence, how I would
bring a paragraph together,
when I would not opt for a
paragraph and go for
a visual instead.
Thinking about what a table of
contents means and why there
wouldn't be a navigation bar
as you turn the pages.
It started to make more sense
that if I was trying to
innovate for the sake
of innovation, it
might miss the target.
If I was trying to innovate
based on the dilemma, you
start to see greater
opportunity, greater clarity
through empathy.
And so this is why I believe
that the future of innovation
actually lies at the center
of, say, data science and
social science.
Because essentially, the people
that we're trying to
connect with, the people that
matter to us, well, they have
an audience of their own.
And their audience has an
audience of their own.
And they live in this ecosystem
where they don't
have to step outside of it.
It's fulfilling to them.
It's fulfilling to us.
We capture experiences, we share
experiences that are
important to us.
And if anything isn't making a
correlation in this regard,
then you're missing an
opportunity to extend your
reach, to extend your value,
your purpose, your mission.
And when I talk to businesses,
a lot of them will sit there
and say, we get what
you're saying.
So we think the answer, then, is
going to be in technology,
and then also better
understanding millennials.
So we're bringing on millennial
marketers.
We're bringing on folks in
HR who better understand
millennials.
And you realize, cool.
All right.
But it's not just about
an age group.
It's about behavior.
And I refer to this
greater-connected society as
Generation C, where the C
stands for connected.
And the reason I do that is
because when you study how,
say, a 49-year-old uses their
tablet, their social network,
and their smartphone, they
start to exhibit
millennial-like behaviors.
My mother, for example,
is, I believe, a
millennial at heart.
She's too connected.
She's too social.
And sometimes I've had to
consider blocking her because
of how active she is in tagging
posts and pictures and
what have you.
But in that regard, though,
the way that she makes
decisions has also changed.
She's watching television
with her tablet.
She's sharing things
in real time.
She's capturing and sharing
experiences.
So to her, what becomes
important has to fly through
the stream, has to fly
through her network.
It doesn't necessarily have to
be in a billboard or a print
magazine or on a television
show or commercial.
So the idea is just segregating
by age or
demographic--
sure, it makes sense
in some regards.
But I think if we look at
behavior there's a bigger
opportunity because behavior--
by the way, if you just add
colors to this bike, I see
that driving up and down the
street all the time.
It's a very talented move,
if you ask me.
But in reality, technology just
becomes an extension of
who we are at all times.
I hear parents--
I interviewed Katie Couric for
my web show, and she just sort
of talked about the frustration
she has, for
example, of being a parent and
trying to get her kids to look
away from the smartphone during
dinner or to put the
phone down while they're
watching TV or movies.
And essentially, what we're
trying to do is force people
to go through their lives in
the way that we grew up, in
the way that we learned.
When, in fact, it is us, I
think, who have to learn.
Look, I'm not a millenial.
I like to pretend
I am, though.
When you look at how a young
child approaches a flat-screen
television, it's natural for
them to want to pinch
and zoom and swipe.
If you can hand them a remote
control, there is just
absolutely no way that would
make sense in any type of
intuition of why you need
so many buttons to
control that thing.
And then if you look at how many
controls you have just in
the living room alone, it just
doesn't make as much sense.
And what we're starting to do
is take this philosophy--
processes of how we make
decisions, why we're making
decisions--
and you come back to that
"Undercover Boss" TV series.
And you realize that the people
making decisions about
the future welfare of the
business, the company, the
government, the livelihood of
whatever it touches, they're
making these decisions based on
life as they know it, not
life as they don't.
And this is why I believe
that thinking--
I laugh when I see
this picture.
But the reality is that
to them, that is
the best party ever.
And so better understanding why
that moment is shareable
and why they're connected to
their device and to figure out
how to capture attention and
to be part of that moment
requires a completely different
process leading up
to it-- how you talk, how you
engage, how you keep people
engaged, how you understand what
they're trying to do, and
how you help facilitate what
they're trying to do.
What you realize is that,
essentially, you're just
solving for yourself.
Because this is as much about
trying to get your attention
as it is trying to be relevant
to a person who has different
needs, different expectations.
Because the more that you become
connected, the more you
become informed.
The more you become informed,
the more you become empowered.
The more you become empowered,
the more demanding you become.
Real-time, personalization--
you are at the center
of all of this.
And if things aren't meeting
your needs or expectations,
you share that with your
greater network.
You let those around you know.
There used to be a joke that
only social media experts have
problems with airlines.
And the joke is because you
hear about it all the time
where they're tweeting that
United or JetBlue or
Southwest--
that, my flights delayed
five minutes.
WTF!
Really?
It's not really a problem.
Sometimes it's a problem.
But the reality is that
businesses don't even know
what to do with that.
Oh, we're so sorry.
Here's an 800 number.
Call us.
Or here's an email address.
That's not going to happen
because that's not the way
that I work.
And if we want to connect, we
can't think about channels as
being ways for us to talk at
your, for us to come up with
some beautiful brand or some
story or some value
proposition and stuff it into
as many channels with as
little effort as possible.
I actually believe that when we
innovate based on problems,
based on behavior, it's like
looking at the remote control.
You start to see that the way
things are and the way things
could be are, in fact,
different.
The fact that businesses,
decision-makers in general
still think that we make
decisions in a linear fashion
around a funnel is funny, so
much so that I call it a
cluster funnel because it's
this great masquerade.
The persuasion--
think of that as marketing
or branding, some clever,
creative, gorgeous ad.
It's to persuade you
to think about us.
And then we have some deal, some
hook, some incentive to
bring you in to the point where
you have to exchange
with us something, whether it's
vote, whether it's money,
what have you.
And then once we have
you, there's
always a great distance.
We don't need you.
And if you need us, well, we
have processes for you, then,
to start to try to
engage with us.
But we might need you
at some point.
We have a new product, we
have a new initiative
that needs a vote.
So we call that the
reenchantment.
And after the reenchantment,
we just place you into this
governance system that is either
CRM or some database
that's falling apart.
But there's just no way to keep
you informed or engaged,
to build a relationship that
goes beyond a transaction.
In the '90s, there was a book
called "The Experience
Economy" that a friend of
mine, Joe Pine, wrote.
He said, if you think about
being in the business of
products, you're going
to fail over time.
If you think about being in the
experience business where
a product is one of the things
that brings an experience to
life, then that represents
the future of engagement.
And I actually believe that's
true because if you think
about what it is that we share
in all of these networks,
across all of these devices,
they're always experiences.
It's very experiential.
It's a very emotional landscape
in which we've woven
through this technology,
through devices.
We share what we love, we share
what we hate, we share
what's meh.
Connecting in that way, then,
you start to see that an
emotional layer, an experiential
layer is required
to be defined by you and lived
through by those who are
important to you.
It's more of a journey, not a
funnel, where everything that,
say, related to Google, related
to any business,
related to anything, are
stitched together based on
shared experiences before,
during, and after
transactions.
Always--
it doesn't go away.
It's not Snapchat.
These experiences don't
self destruct.
They start to culminate,
much like a
Google index, for example.
And these shared
experiences are
always on, always available.
Think about the Lazyweb
for a moment.
Some people won't even
use Google search.
They'll just go right to their
network of choice and say, I'm
thinking about, does anyone
know, can anyone recommend, so
that they can bring the answers
to them without
leaving one particular window.
And when we get those answers,
we're forced to walk in these
steps, in these click paths,
in these journeys that are
defined for an old way of
thinking, a linear flow that
just doesn't work.
It's almost like the
remote control.
It serves a purpose, but we're
forcing people to use
something and do things
our way, not a
way that's more natural.
I dug up a very interesting
report from the Google
Insights team-- it was called
"The Multi-Screen World"--
that I thought was pretty
interesting.
And it studied how people made
decisions and how those
decisions came to life
across screens.
Were they able to complete
something with one screen?
Did they have to screen hop?
Did they complement
one another?
And what this told me was aside
from how people are
using it, they're using every
device differently.
And what if we could better
understand what the nature of
that screen was, what the
intention of that screen was,
what the intention of that
outcome would be, and then
redesign the UI, the UX, around
everything so that it's
efficient, it's natural,
it's native.
I'm not sure how many of you
have read the book "The
Cluetrain Manifesto."
I think it came out
10 or 11 years ago.
And in the book, the authors
talked about how the future
was going to be driven by
conversations, that all
markets were conversations.
And at some point those
conversations would become
more powerful, more defining
than any effort you could do
in terms of branding or
marketing or influence.
When I think about that, they
were so right that it's not
just about conversations.
Really, what it's about is this
idea that conversations
are expressions of
experiences.
The future of markets, business,
education, what have
you, is all driven
by experience.
And I was inspired by Google's
work around the zero moment of
truth a couple years ago.
And for those who don't know the
zero moment of truth, it's
this idea that when something
captures your attention,
you're going to essentially
Google it to
learn more about it.
What I found fascinating about
that was it was just one of a
series of moments of truth.
You take away the funnel, you
take away the journey, you
take away this idea of
conversations, and you just
realize that as a consumer, as a
human being, when we want to
make a decision, there are just
four moments of truth
that happen that affect how we
make a decision and how in
turn we affect how other
people make a decision.
What I found fascinating,
though, is what happens in a
world where maybe we don't
have our laptop first?
Maybe google.com isn't the
first place we go.
Maybe we go to another Google
property like YouTube because
maybe it's easier to look up a
video on a smartphone than it
is a website.
I, for one, for example,
can't even read a
product manual anymore.
I can't even read websites
anymore just because they're
not necessarily written
for human beings.
They're written for the people
who signed off on the check to
pay for the design.
For example, I'm a
big photographer.
I love digital SLRs.
I just picked up a new
camera recently.
I was wowed by the beauty
of their advertisements.
When I opened up the box and I
looked at the manual, I swear
it was created in 1927.
It was illustrated poorly.
Sorry, I'm not going to the
brand because it's on video.
But I had to go to YouTube in
order to figure out what I
needed to do.
And I couldn't find any videos
by the manufacturer.
Instead, I found videos from
other people like me who
couldn't find answers who
answered questions, who
demonstrated capabilities.
It's fascinating to me that in
that moment of truth, the
company was saved because it
had committed consumers,
people who cared enough
to actually use the
channels the right way.
So what if we were thoughtful in
the approach and say, look,
I understand you're not going
to find what you need.
You're not going to
like this manual.
So we're going to give
you other options.
And we're not going to just rely
upon you to add to the
ecosystem to find solutions.
We understand you're
going to go around.
Google research shows that every
year the number of touch
points seems to grow, often
doubles, because they can,
because technology
is pervasive.
It's everywhere.
But what keeps coming back in
those moments of truth aren't
the things that we
think they are--
not the things that we're
designing like websites and
long forms of copy
and collateral.
It's all experiences, the
experiences people have and
the experiences people share.
For example, as an author I have
to rely, whether I like
it or not, on Amazon reviews,
on iTunes reviews, on just
reviews in general more than
I can rely on my own
website for the book.
More people are going to believe
what you say rather
than what I say.
So if I know that, why wouldn't
I start to work with
my own teams or my own
consumers to build an
ecosystem that when someone asks
a question in Google or
somebody puts a series
of keywords in
YouTube, for example--
why would I leave it to surprise
or to chance in what
comes back in those
moments of truth?
Why wouldn't I design that
moment of truth, much in the
same way that we designed
SEO SEM?
So if we could work with
people to design the
experiences that we want them to
have, that we want them to
share, wouldn't it be
fascinating in that world
where we know what comes back
when a question's asked?
So I'm just going to kind of
jump ahead because I think the
future of anything that we do is
about creating experiences.
Because if you can design an
experience that people need or
that they expect--
or that we understand the
problems that they have today
and we could design something
that solves for it--
then we could merge the
real world and the
virtual world into one.
That becomes useful.
It's not just a utility.
It's experiential.
So I think about--
I'm a geek, so I think about
stuff like this-- "The Matrix"
or "Inception." The one thing
that both of those movies had
was an architect, this person
who was responsible for
designing the landscape.
You still were you and
you still moved
through this landscape.
But they created a world that
was important to you, that you
could navigate or would want
to navigate around.
And that is the way I think
about experiences.
Because in what I call the
ultimate moment of truth,
you're going to experience
something.
Like if I don't like a product
manual, I'm going to share
that I don't like a product
manual because
I'm going to search.
I'm going to ask questions.
That experience you have every
step of the journey--
before, during, and after
a transaction--
is something that's shared.
It's something that's indexed.
It's something that's
findable.
And if we're not designing what
that experience could be,
we don't only leave it to chance
for what is shared.
What is shared actually becomes
the culmination of
your brand.
A brand is not a logo.
It's an ethos.
It is what it represents.
It's what it symbolizes.
We would often try to complement
a brand with a
vision statement or a
mission statement.
With my last book, I read
about 1,500 of those.
And I found three that we're
really meaningful, human, that
actually spoke to me.
Like, oh, I see where
you're trying to go.
I think that vision is something
I can align with.
But in a world where experiences
become you,
there's always an experience
divide.
There's this brand promise--
what you say you're going to do,
what you say I should have
as a customer or as a
stakeholder or as
part of your community.
And then there's the experience
that I actually have.
What I actually have
and what I share--
the more this happens, the more
connected we become, the
more reality it is.
It's the truth.
And this transparency starts
to become a way of life.
This truth, then, is not
anything you can manipulate,
you can try to influence
or steer.
It's something you have
to aspire to create.
And I think this is
a great thing.
I don't know how many of you
have heard of or used the
Pebble watch.
But I was following that
Kickstarter program when it
shattered all the records.
I was an early Kickstarter
backer for this product--
well, a whole bunch of
products because
I think it's fun.
But what it promised sounded
amazing, so amazing that a lot
of people backed it.
What the real experience was,
however, was very different.
And the most common complaint,
other than the screen dying,
was the company never responding
to anybody.
And now you have this brand
promise and a real world
series of experiences that
affect what I'm going to do as
a new customer.
These reviews, these experiences
really start to
influence whether or not you're
going to follow in the
same footsteps willfully or if
you're going to rely on your
peers to help you
make a decision.
And in an emotional world, this
is true for Amazon, this
is true-- this is
from Best Buy.
What's true about emotional
experiences when they're
shared is they're either a
five or they're are one.
The fives are people who
believe in the promise.
The ones are people who didn't
believe the promise and who
had a different experience.
The ones can become threes,
fours, or fives with
engagement, with learning--
understanding how that
experience failed to meet
expectations and how
to fix that.
So all of the complaints from
people who said that the
company didn't care, didn't
listen, didn't follow up,
well, there's a way
to fix that.
And any time somebody tries
to fix anything a
natural thing happens.
It's called reciprocity.
You're actually thankful.
You actually appreciate that
somebody reached out, heard
you, listened to you.
And it changes how you
feel about things.
Often, you actually change
your review.
You share something publicly.
You tell people that you
heard from them.
And that's important.
At the same time, it's a sad
state of the world when you
actually get help and it's
that transforming.
But that's a whole
other discussion.
So I believe that the future
of shared experiences isn't
just about innovation or
coming up with ideas or
finding ways to use technology
to just be ahead of the curve.
I actually think that the
greatest form of innovation is
when you are the dilemma's
innovator.
There are a lot of problems in
the world that I think create
a lot of opportunities.
And with that, those
opportunities can be inspired
by, enhanced by empathy.
The world, I think--
every decision maker, every
leader in the world, every
manager in the world could use
that "Undercover Boss" moment
because it's inspiring.
It makes you think
differently.
It makes you see differently.
And that's the point.
Because when you can see things
differently, when you
can feel things differently,
you are living in an
experience layer--
a layer, by the way, I believe
that is user defined.
This is entitled, "How Computers
Are Born." I thought
it was funny.
But more importantly, it was a
visualization that got me to
see differently.
And that is whether it's a
business, whether it's a
government, whether you're an
author, if you try to think
about what it is you're creating
or delivering and
what it takes to bring
that to life--
when you start with empathy
and thinking for different
type of person, you find that
the end result, the outcome,
the deliverable, whatever it is,
is different than if you
try to approach it with
iteration or just pure
innovation.
And I think this is
complementary to ways that we
do things today or it's
revolutionary and just
completely usurping how
we do things today.
To get this, by the way, it
wasn't like I called the
publisher and said, hey, I need
you to not print the book
the way you usually do.
I have a whole different
shape, and I
need different paper.
Could you guys find a different
printing press, too?
And what do you guys usually
pay for printing
each copy of the book?
Because I'm going to need
you to triple it.
It was a very, very painful
conversation to have.
In fact, the whole idea of the
design delayed the book by six
or eight months, to the point
where I was going to give up.
But thinking differently about
what you're trying to do and
why it's important,
that's purpose.
And purpose is contagious.
And I believe when you start
with that, only good things
can come out of it.
But at the very least, what ends
up happening is this idea
of relevance.
Relevance becomes an outcome
because you're considering
every aspect of it-- the brand
experience, the user
experience, the customer
experience--
where the one thing that ties
them all together is
experience.
It was thoughtful, it was
designed, it was reinforced,
and it was connected.
So what I'd just love to close
out with-- and if you have any
questions, we'll throw to you00
is this idea, though,
that innovation isn't something
that has to be
driven by technology.
Innovation is something that
I actually believe is most
meaningful and most relevant
when it's something that you
feel, and it's something that
inspires you because that part
inspires those around you.
And I only just started on
my path or my journey to
rethinking the way that
I would do things.
If I have to change the way I
talk or the way I write and
just not take it for granted
that I just do things the way
I always have-- if I want to
be relevant to a different
type of reader or to a different
type of student,
then I have to actually
try to be relevant.
I can't just assume
that it would be.
So at the future of
whatever it is--
whether it's business or
government or music or
television--
the greatest innovation is
going to happen when you
actually care enough about what
you're trying to enable
as much as the experience that
you're hoping to deliver.
AUDIENCE: I get the idea
you're giving.
So do you have any just initial,
concrete, baby steps
for us, as employees, thinking
about our own
teams and our leaders?
Just about how to start
implementing some of the ideas
that you're talking
about here?
BRIAN SOLIS: So I'll start with
just talking to the team,
or talking to users, to get a
better understanding of what
it is that they're experiencing,
what they're
feeling, what a day in the
life is like, their
opportunities, their
frustrations, their
challenges.
And I do it one-on-one.
So it's not like
a focus group.
It's like an interview, like
a therapy session.
Because then when you disarm
those who you're talking to,
you get the truth.
And in the truth-- and
this has yet to
fail me, by the way--
in the truth comes insights.
And when you present those
truths back to the team,
there's a lot of surprise and
often, like the ones and fives
in a review, there's
often surprise and
there's often denial.
And what ends up happening,
though, is like that
experience divide.
There's just always a divide of
what you think you're doing
and what's really felt
and what's happening.
But also, within that divide
comes this idea of what your
next steps would
be to close it.
It becomes purposeful.
And that always, always works.
People align around that.
If they don't, then
they don't care.
But I haven't seen
that happen.
But when they can align around
something, its purposeful.
That's where it always starts.
It's not a complex process.
It's just a process
of understanding.
It's like that "Undercover
Boss" moment.
You're just walking in the steps
to better understand
what's happening,
what's feeling.
AUDIENCE: So thank you, first
of all, for coming out and
talking to us.
But I really like the part where
you said that with the
Pebble watch, the people who
commented on the ones could
have probably been brought up
two, three, or fours with just
engagement.
But in this progressing world
where engagement's becoming
more and more important, do you
think if you can only have
one, is personalization or
consistency more important in
your engagement with
your customers?
BRIAN SOLIS: I actually think
that consistency is probably
going to outweigh
personalization, at least
initially, because in that
Pebble example, there is no
uniformity in the solution.
There is uniformity
in the problem.
I mean, it's just consistent.
You read every review, even
those that have great reviews.
It's just the problem
is consistent.
So anyway, in that regard, what
if you just aimed for
consistency in the experience
that people are going to have?
What if you aim for consistency
in the promise delivery?
Maybe it's not the
right promise.
But you were consistent
with the promise.
From there, though, the idea of
personalization, I think,
can be unlocked.
It's almost harder to create
alignment between the desired
experience and the experience
people have.
If you can do that, people
become a form of
engagement for you.
It's almost like advocacy.
And that could have
been solved for.
When you look at the best
products, there is a sense of
uniformity because the
experience is what was designed.
And it creates this excitement
or this enthusiasm within the
community where people will
actually start to answer other
people's questions.
So this is going to sound silly,
but it's true for the
Vitamix blender world, by the
way, which I've just found out
is a church.
People are really religious
about this blender.
And they are answering all of
the questions that people have
about it before anybody from
Vitamix can even get to it.
Actually, I haven't seen
anybody from Vitamix.
Not to say they're not, but
in every case the idea of
consistency was delivered in the
product and therefore, the
idea of personalization came
from peer-to-peer.
So pretty interesting
in that regard.
Any other questions?
Well, as an analyst, when I try
to solve for businesses
who actually want to survive,
I'm almost like a lawyer.
I have all the evidence that's
necessary to fight my case, to
say, look, we're actually on a
path to irrelevance than we
are on a path to relevance.
The reason why there isn't a
prescription is because it's
never a problem of them not
wanting to do the right thing.
It's always a cultural problem
of them thinking that they're
doing the right thing and that
everything that they've
learned, everything that they
do on a daily basis, is sort
of managing the business in a
direction that they believe it
to be most successful.
So this is why the idea of
anthropology came, at least,
into my world.
The stakeholder interview thing
is interesting because
when I report out to an
executive at a company and
they actually see that what they
think is happening and
what they're managing toward is
not the reality, it always
creates very interesting
discussions.
And what they always do after
that is they form--
using enterprise words, their
words, not mine--
is they form either a steering
committee or a task force to
go learn more about it.
This has to do with
part innovation--
so they'll move people here to
Silicon Valley to talk to you,
to talk to other companies to
see what's on the horizon,
what's trending, what
are they learning.
They'll also look to their
folks in the social media
department, for example,
to listen.
What's taking place?
What are we hearing?
What are we not missing?
But in every case, the problem
is the bottom line.
When you look at that stat about
companies that turned
over, there was one time when
Kodak was incredibly
profitable.
So the one thing that I hear
every time is that, look, our
last quarter was this.
Why do we even need
to listen to you?
And it becomes a culture of
management rather than a
culture of leadership.
There's an interesting
infographic that's going
around over the last couple of
days that showed the number of
executives who either got bailed
out, who got fired with
the golden parachute, and
ultimately how many of those
folks drove those companies
into the ground.
What creates this demise is
anything and everything.
A lot of times, it's greed, a
lack of transparency, a lack
of leadership.
So that's why the problem is
there isn't a prescription.
I do think that the solution,
though, is around creating the
desired experiences that meet
expectations or at least beat
what it is that customers
expect.
At the back of the book,
I talk about the
psychology of change.
How you get somebody to
see that there's a
problem with smoking?
And then how do you get them to
quit smoking in order to do
something differently?
So a lot of this, I
realized, was part
politician, part lawyer--
not just building the case but
also championing the case.
In every case, what ends up
convincing someone who's
preserving power, they
understand that there's a way
to get more power by thinking
differently or investing in an
alternative strategy.
So you almost have
to feed into it.
And very rarely does it happen
because they saw it.
It happened because the team
that they've surrounded
themselves with to insulate
them has said this is the
direction that they
have to go.
So in many cases, the team that
surrounds the decision
maker is not the team that sees
the opportunity, either.
So for us, for me, every single
time I have to get--
it's good, old-fashioned
politics.
I have to get what I need
because I see an opportunity,
because I did the math to see
that it's an opportunity, and
then get an executive sponsor
that's in that inner circle to
at least allow me to prove it.
When that happens, then that
inner circle invests in this
innovation committee,
this steering
committee, this task force.
And then they're chartered with
tangible things to bring
about change.
So what ends up happening is
that three, four, five years
from now, those little pilots
have added into an augmented
or a complementary program
that brings about change.
It doesn't just say, look, we're
going to compete for the
future and we're going double
down on all this stuff.
It's incremental.
So I look at the Tata
group out of India.
And the one thing that I like
about them is that they didn't
know the answer.
They didn't know how to stay
competitive or how to stay
innovative.
So they put it in the hands
of their employees to just
innovate, made it part
of the culture.
They said management had to take
ideas and that they would
then be measured by how
they translated
those ideas into programs.
It was a cultural thing.
Now, that's led to very
interesting things like
low-cost cars, a lot of
improvements in processes.
But in that regard, the leader
of the organization said that
there's an opportunity here.
In other ways, you have to
create that opportunity.
It has to become part
of culture.
And the only way to do that is
to get it into the inner
circle to affect the ultimate
decision maker.
Because nothing happens
from the bottom up.
It always has to happen
from the top down.
It's complicated, hence ending
the book on all these
psychological steps to get
people to see and how to fight
for change.
One of things that I'll bring,
and I'll bring it back to
higher level.
But there is no easy answer.
I was really inspired by Joseph
Campbell's the hero's journey.
Because in the hero's journey,
there was this common path
that mythological leaders
had followed.
And there was a lot of
challenge, a lot of doubt, a
lot of renaissance.
And I sort of adapted that,
saying, you're going to be met
with every obstacle that's going
to dissuade you from
doing what you want to do.
It's not even in your job
description or your
responsibility to try to bring
about this type of change.
But there's a great reward for
it, and here's 21 steps to
follow to at least have a shot
at it and to create strength
and unity around you.
Because without it, waiting
for it to come from
the top down is--
it's just not going to happen.
That's why Kodak
is what it is.
I spent about five years of
research looking at all the
companies that just failed
and created an
infographic around it.
And it's sobering,
to say the least.
But there wasn't one common
thing that led to the demise
of some of the brands that
we all grew up with.
But what was common was just
this inability to see that
there were alternative
possibilities for the future.
And that's why I think that that
hero's journey, what this
really starts to inspire is what
happens if you and I can
just start to try to answer this
question and start to try
to bring about the change or at
least create the need for
change or make a case for an
opportunity for change.
And then you become the best
practices or the series of
steps that we follow.
And that's the book that
I hope to write next.
And I wanted to try to spark
a revolution around that.
So guys, thank you for your
time and attention this
afternoon, and enjoy
the long weekend.